So let's talk about the role of
the storage in a computer system.
It keeps all the files, the programs,
the data, all the settings,
the operating system, everything.
And also,
our virtual memory is implemented using
storage because we cannot fit all
the data that the application actually
wants to access to physical memory.
Some of those pages are actually on
disk and when the program accesses them,
they're loaded into the physical memory.
But meanwhile, they're sitting in our
storage, for example, on our disk.
So storage is important, not only
to keep data, but also to extend
our virtual memory so that we think we
have more memory than we actually have.
For both uses of storage,
we care about performance,
mainly throughput and latency.
Throughput is how many bytes per
second can we get out of our, for
example, disk.
Latency, once we request a page of data,
when are we going to get it back?
And then storage, this is improving, but
not as quickly as the processor
speed is improving,
whereas the latency is improving,
but very slowly.
The reduction in storage
latency is even slower
than the reduction in DRAM latency.
So processor are getting faster and
faster.
DRAM is getting faster but
lagging behind processors and
becoming slower and slower,
relative to the processors, and
then storage is falling
further behind DRAM itself.
In addition to performance, we are also
really concerned with reliability.
If our processor fails, our system
temporarily doesn't work until we
replace the processor, but then we can
boot up the system and it works again.
But if our disk fails,
we lose our programs, data settings,
etc., which is much, much worse
than just a processor failing.
So we are much more worried about
the reliability of our storage
than we are about most of the other
elements of our computer system.
And finally, the types of storage
that we can use are very diverse.
We can have magnetic disks,
our traditional hard drives,
optical disks such as CDs and
DVDs, tape for backup,
flash drives that are much faster than
most of the other ones, and so on.